- What's up everybody.
Our next guest was a Sports
Illustrated swimsuit model
who went on to have a successful career
in both acting and business.
She's also busy being a mom of three,
that's the more important job,
please welcome Molly Sims everybody!
(upbeat music)
That's beautiful!
I love your dress.
- I put on a dress.
- And it's- Oh! And open in the back!
- I've had this dress
like- for about a year.
- Oh cause you don't dress
up for- we don't go anywhere.
- So there you go!
- Well, I was going to
ask you about your kids
but everybody always
asks about kids first.
How are you?
- Oh! I'm good.
- You're good.
- I was so happy to leave my house.
I was so happy to leave
just my room and my
other room and the kids.
Where are you going Mom?
Where are you going?
- Away.
- Yeah.
- Far far away. To Burbank.
- To Burbank.
(Kelly laughs)
It's been a lot though!
Especially as a mom
just trapped home with
your kids, that's a lot!
- I'm trapped home with my kids.
I hide a lot.
They find me in the pantry.
(Kelly laughs)
They find me in my closet.
They find me eating and drinking.
They find me literally they can find me
and I have quite a big house.
I'm not going to lie.
They find me.
- Yeah. They find you.
They sense it it's like-
- I was- the other day I
was talking to my girlfriend
and she was- we were just,
I don't know, just talking.
I was like behind a chair in my room, like
in like, you know, criss-cross
freaking applesauce, like
and I'm like, they're
like, what are you doing?
I'm like, I'm in my own mommy fort.
So anyway.
- All my kids do are- they make forts.
- Oh we made a fort this morning before
they left for school.
- Every time.
The only reason why that's not because my
I threw a Neverland party for my kids.
So there's like teepees and stuff.
So they're not, but usually
every day is a fort.
I'm like, can we build something else?
Can we call it a castle?
Can we call it as you know,
something, a treehouse?
- Can we call it anything with-
no, we have, we have forts
upstairs and downstairs.
We put a fort in his bed last night.
And before I left, like the
couch had been taken apart
with every type of pillow, sheet.
They like just go-
- Cushions are all over the floor.
- All over the floor.
- Thanks cause that's super clean.
Have you talked about this
on your- cause you have a new podcast.
Do you talk about this
stuff on your podcast?
- We haven't!
Emese- which I'm so excited.
We have a podcast called
Lipstick on the Rim
and it's talking about beauty and wellness
and she's my best friend of 17 years.
I met her because I complimented her hair
in Sundance at a film festival.
She was working- she
was actually working for
Diane Von Furstenberg or Club Monaco.
And we, I said, I don't know.
We kind of connected.
I'm like, oh, call me.
I didn't really mean call me.
- Yeah.
- I mean I was just like, call me.
But anyway, she called me
and kind of kept in touch.
And that was 17 years ago.
And we talk- when we were
thinking- I was going to
do the podcast by myself and I was like,
you're the one like I love to talk to you
about all things beauty, wellness.
It's so fun.
We, you know, to take on something else
has been kind of crazy, but
it's something that I really
wanted to do. I do.
I love connecting people.
I love, you know, I love
sharing ideas and I get
like you I'm- I get to work
with so many amazing people.
- I love talking with people.
I love learning about-
- I love it. I love it.
And I love sharing what I've learned.
- Yeah.
- And we keep it real.
Both of our moms recently
passed away and you know,
she has- she lives in Summit, New Jersey.
She has three little
girls and I have three.
So it's just, I love when-
- Do y'all talk about that? The loss?
- The loss, we talk about every day.
- I was gonna say that- a
lot of people would probably
especially this past year, so
many people have lost people.
- We talk a lot.
We, I work with a woman
named Claire Bidwell.
She lost both her parents, one at 17
and the other one when she
was in her early twenties.
All about grief
and it just really helps.
And I, you know, I love having
those real conversations
because I think so many
people are like, oh,
how do you look like that?
Or what do you do?
And you know, I work at it and it's hard.
And I have, you know, a crazy
background with modeling and
you know, does, you know,
body dysmorphia and like all
of that, that, you know,
a lot of people don't know
because you know, I'm not
really going to open that up.
But I decided to, with these conversations
because I do think it's-
- I think it's a perfect platform for it.
- It's the perfect platform and you know,
things don't come easy.
You know, I do have to work for it.
I hate when I'll ask someone
like, oh, what did you do?
I'm like, oh, I had
hamburgers and French fries
and you know, I'm like, no, you didn't.
You know what I mean?
Like, you eat like lettuce.
- You eat the lettuce and tomato.
- You eat the lettuce and the tomato.
- No, but I definitely,
and I love, you know
I love doing with her, you know?
- Yeah.
- And it's been fun.
We also got to talk to a
girl named It's Me, Tinks.
- Wait.
- Do you know Tink?
- No.
- Oh my God, you guys have to follow her.
Her name is Christina.
Her name is It's Me, Tinks.
And she talks to boys,
Botox, and rich mom culture.
And you just have to-
- Like, she pokes fun at it? Obviously.
- Oh yeah. It is phenomenal.
Phenomenal.
(Kelly laughs)
- Well, everybody
Molly's podcast is called
Lipstick on the Rim.
You got to check it out.
It's available now, wherever
you listen to your podcasts.